[Music]
all right hi everyone we're at one of
the last sessions of the day so I figure
that people are a little
tired I'll probably need a little bit of
your concentration uh this is going to
be an important topic we're going to
talk about data in machine learning the
title of our session is high performance
feature engineering for predictive and
geni workloads and I'm going to be
demoing vertex AI feature
store my name is Alex Martin I'm the
product manager for vertex AI features
store and with me is Cass s all the way
from Japan he's our uh developer
Advocate and also a resident generative
AI
expert today we'll talk about data in
machine learning the many problems that
that you may encounter as you try to use
data in a m then I would introduce
feature store as a solution to many of
those
problems Cass will do a cool demo of how
you can actually use feature store and
we'll wrap up with some feedback from
the customers who already tried future
store and also helped us develop it so
let's kick it
off now in our
industry models get the spotlight if you
look at all of the new newspaper
articles all the blog posts they talk
about the over complexing architectures
and all the different ways that we're
making the tensor
flow however if you ask actual AI
practitioners who ship projects almost
all of them would tell you that the
fastest most sure way to improve your
machine learning outcomes is to focus on
your data easier said than done because
there's a lot of challenges in how to
use data for ML it's right there at the
center of everything you do in mlops ml
features are compiled into a training
data set that actually is the foundation
for your model to learn from and act as
you wanted to
act and then the same features need to
be passed into the training endpoint
often at a very very low latency and
with exact same Transformations just so
that you can avoid train serving scoop
and I've heard some tell me that oh but
this is a generative AI ERA this is
foundation models all the data is encoda
they kind of like apis it's no longer as
important well if you heard terms like
rag grounding fine-tuning these are all
techniques that are actually used to
make llm apps work in production and all
of those techniques are rooted in
effective use of data and if you're one
of those few companies that actually
trains the generative models then
nothing change for you you still have to
compile these massive data sets to
actually improve your models now it's
already pretty clear that very few
companies are actually going to be
training the models training the large
models and most companies in order for
you to Future proof your business
whether you're an ml company or any
company for that matter the best way is
to compile a really good predictive data
set so there are some challenges in
actually having that data and using it
for your ml models number one is being
able to centralize all of the features
that you're using across different
projects and different
organizations I've seen many many teams
where you'd have exactly the same
feature something trivial like average
revenue per customer per day the same
feature being created in multiple
projects held even in the same project
sometimes where it's diligently there
with an ETL pipeline removing
outliers um cleaning up various uh uh
various attributes and all of this is
done in exactly the same way for exactly
the same feature twice or three times
because the data scientists didn't know
that this feature already existed and
another team has created it has shipped
it there is a model running it but they
had to create it from
scratch next up is train serving skew
probably the
single most popular reason why models
disappointing production train serving
skew is any time when whatever you've
done in training cannot be replicated
in
serving an edge case of train Sur skew
is data leakage and this is probably the
shest way to crush a data scientist
spirit is to show them that the reason
their model is finally behaving well is
not their grit or their smarts but
because they leaked some data into the
training
variable this happens all the time many
of us have stories to show how you've
done everything right but then you
forgot that this one variable was not
correctly looked up in point in time and
the data leaked into your model and then
when you deployed it in production it
didn't it didn't work well serving
environments actually really constrained
so train Sur SK is often inevitable
because whatever you've done at your
training time you've used some common
libraries maybe you've used something
like pandas that's not super performance
oriented but it's just very nice to use
you can't really use that at serving
time with latency constraints and many
other uh problems that you just don't
experience when you try to use your data
um in in a common environment like a
notebook which brings me to my second
point my third point that realtime
serving is very
hard just about any team that I talk to
that has engaged in creating a realtime
serving pipeline has told me that this
was not their most fun
activity and uh they would share some
stories on how they've been setting up
the infrastructure how the team
inevitably Grew From one two people to
now dozens and seemingly the problems
just keep keep coming much faster than
they can address them reconciling memory
between multiple nodes dealing with read
write congestions with hotspotting with
load Spikes all of these are problems of
real-time suring and there is a reason
why real-time data processing is
typically the last topic of any data
engineering curriculum it's really hard
in fact the amount of hurdles that teams
have to jump through to make sure that
their data can perform in real time with
low latency is so high that many teams
just don't go there and they only
operate on batch workloads and I've seen
many projects which can clearly be
improved by replacing some kind of batch
workload with a real time end point but
the teams just don't go there they they
feel like this is going to be way too
complex of an architecture to maintain
um and even though batch serving in a
lot of times is an edge case of real
time um they still they still don't do
it the worst part about it is that the
user experience is almost always better
for for a real-time serving because
people just don't like to wait and if
your API can respond quickly or the
faster it can really respond generally
the better your system
is and if it responds fast you still
have a problem of serving the right data
which brings me to my last topic of
future engineering any of the data
scientists who actually engaged in
multiple new projects know this kind of
beginning of a project where just start
from a blank state of a data set trying
to figure out which features to use
trying to transform your data explore it
I think there's multiple studies that
say something like 80% of data scientist
time is spent on data cleanup data
processing and feature engineering so
maybe this whole affair should not be
called machine learning but feature
engineering um and the process actually
hasn't changed over the time despite
seeing many like Innovations and you
know with deep learning and Transformer
architectures feature engineering is
largely the same that it was like 10
years ago you still have to just take
the data manipulate it
apply some transformation methods review
them train the model with them
understand it and likely be disappointed
and do all all over again until you find
some features that actually work there's
many algorithmic methods that help you
do this much faster like feature search
algorithms automated feature engineering
algorithms and they're still only in the
nency of their
popularity so this was just a subset of
some problems and I know it's the end of
the day and hopefully I got you a little
bit worried about well am I doing data
right with my machine learning stack and
you know do I need something to uh to
help me there um so the good news is
that for the rest of my talk I'm
hopefully going to be calming down the
anxiety because feature stores are the
solution to the many of the problems
that I've just described there and they
really are there to create discover
manage and serve ml features at
scale feature stores are kind of like
apis to your data you can think of it as
an interface to the entirety of your dat
data stack they abstract the data
engineering for your data scientists so
they can focus on creating the features
and actually shipping those features
into production so I actually think that
looking back at my diagram earlier today
feature store should be at the center
because you don't usually interact with
the data you interact with the interface
to that data or the tools that that
transform this data and that's exactly
what feature stores are and they kind of
had a bit of an Ascend because just 5
years ago I don't think that the product
even existed and now um in 202
almost every company not just AI leaders
not just the the big names in the EML
space but just about every company
either has a feature store or some
concept of a feature store or is very
actively evaluating
one and that is why I'm so excited to
tell you that vertex AI has a new
feature
store we have completely rebuilt it from
scratch on top of bigquery
this is the best data warehousing and
data processing infrastructure in the
world and we're building rout on top of
it we also completely re-engineered our
serving stack and we now have some of
the lowest latencies for realtime
serving of any features through out
there and those of you who are
experimenting or maybe even not
experimenting but productionizing your
generative AI apps you no longer need a
separate sta to manage data for Gen apps
you can do all of this inside of our
feature store because we have built in
Native methods for working with
instructure data and common tasks for
generative
AI
so the new feature store doesn't just
integrate with bigquery we actually have
worked closely with the bigquery team to
make sure that you can access the big
tables from the feature store without
any
overhead so you you don't have to copy
the data and ingest it into feature
stores like mini products request you
can literally just call them using the
standard bigquery apis it just works
that also is brilliant for any kind of
security setups you have with bqu
already you don't have to replicate them
in featur store they
propagate now our online serving latency
now is at 2 milliseconds this is really
fast this is as fast as you can probably
get there for practical purposes and is
definitely fast enough for you to no
longer worry that you have to optimize
your features for performance your read
latency server side it's going to be
topnotch and of course Google cloud is
one of the leaders in generative AI
applications and research so we had to
make sure that feature St works well for
your generative AI
workloads so we went ahead and we built
in Native support for embeddings in
feature store
that means that you can store the
embeddings in bigquery feature store
would create the index for them it'll
expose the API method to get similar
items you don't have to set up a
separate Vector database you don't have
to copy your data you don't have to
worry about a governance breach you
don't have to worry about syn conflicts
all of this is going to work within the
same system that system being feature
store and I wish I had more time in my
session because the bottom of the slide
is just as important as the top there's
many core feature store features that
are available that I'm only going to
talk about briefly things like
versioning now change management is much
easier it's much more resemblant of your
software engineering practice things
like lineage I mean that deserves its
own slide just all the different ways
that you can trace how the feature
evolved before it enter machine learning
any of you who ever debugged a or any
kind of uh drift problem with machine
learning knows that this can easily be a
week-long procedure if you don't have
any lineage tools
and all the known methods that we have
for point in time lookups web uis sdks
and so forth this is our
architecture you heard me mention that
we're now built on bigquery and you may
have been kind of questioning so what
does it mean so I'm going to illustrate
it for you actually I'm going to start
with a quick story because the most
common feedback we heard on our Legacy
feature store was that it has to work
really well with bigquery so we actually
got together with bigquery team and
we're like how do we integrate how do we
make sure that this is the best
integration out there we started listing
all the things that people expect out of
the bigquery system out of the future
store system like what are we overlap
and very quickly occurred to us that
they're almost the same things that
people ask for so instead of integrating
we decided to build on top of big query
and basically make bigquery the feature
store and it really helps that we are
right next to the bigquery team and we
can actually do that I know that many
companies tried but but couldn't get the
same level of
integration and because it's built on B
it's right there in the middle of my
diagram showing you that you'll use the
native methods for data ingestion for
data reading you can use all the same
SQL you can use all the same processing
all of it is powered by the core
infrastructure that you're likely
already
using as I like to say instead of
bringing your data into the feature
store we bring the feature store to your
data and those of you hopefully very few
who don't know how good bigquery is I
just want to give you a quick summary
bigquery is one of the best data
warehouses in terms of storing the data
retrieving the data and ingesting the
data it integrates with just about any
system out there from jira to Google
analytics to many many different
databases it has a very active Community
if you want to know more about the
Integrations or debug them um and it has
one of the most efficient storage
systems in the
world and feature store does not require
you to do any kind of post processing
when your data is in bigquery so as soon
as it's available there it's available
for uml workloads with no
duplication SQL is what drives big
queries
interface and boy doesn't execute SQL
well just about any transformation
you're going to throw at it is likely
going to complete in
seconds and allow you infinite
flexibility in how you find your
features and I don't have this in my
slide but actually as of this conference
bit no longer supports just SQL we also
have what we called um big frames which
is a pendas like python interface for
bigquery so you can now Define your
Transformations not in just SQL I know a
lot of data scientists are not big fans
but you can actually Define them in your
familiar python you can have some tests
against it so everything as if you're
writing code in your notebook and the
best part about it is that this is just
the interface the execution is still
going to be on the big query
infrastructure meaning that you'll get
the best performance and the highest
scalability out there among any data wre
warehouses and no story about data
warehousing is complete without the talk
on governance and bqu has it all column
level row level data set level table
level you can Define your governance and
your permissions however way you want
and it's always a challenge to make sure
that you're protecting the data but also
not making it a nightmare experience for
somebody who's trying to consume this
data and big Cory has all the controls
for you to make sure the policy is
flexible yet effective and in feature
store we just use it as is you don't
have to rep at which is really really
nice because it really Powers your
governance
Story the one area where big query is
not that great is realtime serving it is
really meant to be a badge processing
warehouse and that's where the feature
store team came in and as I said we've
actually rebuilt our serving stack we
used to be based on cloud bigtable and
it's still an option for all of you
there but we also have a new low latency
serving option which delivers
mindboggling 2 millisecond serving side
latency which is really fast probably
faster than most feature stores out
there and for Anto latency it's in about
5 milliseconds and I know many people
say that latency measurement this kind
of number throwing is really complicated
really depends on the type of workload
on the size of data so we ran quite a
few benchmarks to arrive at at our
numbers and we mostly compared with the
workloads we saw already so we encourage
you to do the same and many of our
benchs actually showed a lower than 2
millisecond late although I don't know
many user experiences who would benefit
lowering latency even more our goal was
to make sure that you have to not worry
about latency anymore you just build
great user experiences and you let
feature store do the rest and to help
you with this we made sure that it's
trivial to set up an online feature
store all you have to do is write create
online store set up your data sync
policy and you're done C is going to
show it in just a minute
minute and not only it's easy to deploy
the feature store it's easy to maintain
it too as you workload Spike we'll
provision more
servers as they go down we'll turn those
servers down make sure that you can
accommodate any workload you want 5,000
QPS 10,000 QPS 50,000 QPS no problem at
all we'll make sure that we scale our
infrastructure accordingly so you don't
have to worry about
it and for the those dealing with
generative AI I'm sure you've heard that
the embeddings is the new most popular
data type at least for
now and you have to know how to work
with this the key operation on
embeddings is similarity search getting
the similar items back there's an entire
industry now in Vector databases trying
to power this use case there's all the
different problems that you can run into
as you try to introduce a new API into
your stack a new storage system into
your stack which is why we decided to
build this inside of the feature store
inside of the same online serving
endpoint you already to use for the rest
of your data that way there is no
governance breach there is no new API
you have to learn maintain Run Security
checks on it's all built in in one
system and our goal is to make sure that
feature store works for all of your data
structured unstructured predictive or
generative all of this can be powered by
feature store
we know that many machine learning use
cases are trained offline Serve online
so the methods for similarity retrieval
are actually going to be available in
big query as well so you can play with
your system as you're training your
model and you can run those methods
offline in distributed fashion and then
with just a few commands you'll deploy
it online and it's going to be available
there for all of your real time
retrieval we take care of building the
index we take care of maintaining the
instances and there is a reason why
there's high performance in the title of
today's session because we can support
just about any embedding sites 1
Gigabyte 10 even hung gigabyte
embeddings indexes are totally fine
you'll still have millisecond latency
responses we're powered by one of the
algorithms that Google has used for many
years even in some Production Services
like Google search and YouTube and we
scale really well across all aspects of
online
survey now
there is much more to the feature store
that I can cover today our data op story
is not going to be complete with just
one slide I hope that I'll have more
follow-ups but we have lineage where you
can see literally you can click through
and see all the tables involved in
creating the feature all the SQL that
runs in between them that's really cool
as I mentioned when you're doing
debugging Lifesaver if you just trying
to run some broad queries and try to
understand like what are the most kind
of Choke points like what to some tables
that power most of my ml workflows you
can do that too there is versioning now
if you ever done change management and
you've just overwritten the future
values I'm sure that your future
consumers have been not very happy with
that practice even though you meant you
had the best intentions but just like
software you don't want your library
that you've been using to just update
randomly on you data is part of your
software in machine learning so you have
to make sure that there's appropriate uh
change management process and that's
usually done through versions you just
publish any you ask everybody to upgrade
you don't force them
to online serving continues to deliver
new challenges for us so there's many
edge cases that we're addressing one of
them being uh hotspotting where you
retrieve the same value over and over
again we created some cash mechanisms to
make sure that this is effective uh
point in time lookups this is a staple
of any feature store these days uh we've
done some performance optimizations
there there's a web UI there's a python
SDK we got you there for all of your
data Ops with vertex feature
store and to show you here is Cass doing
a
[Applause]
demo we we will take a look at how to
use feature store to retrieve feature
values instantly as Alex mentioned and
use them for similarity search for
realtime shopping experience let's
imagine there is a spot Weare Shop
introducing a new AI Kiosk for the
Shoppers they can scan an item with the
kiosk and find similar items instantly
to explore various
options to implement the AI kosk you
need a system like this the first thing
you need to do is the uh to have the big
query table storing item features such
as ID name price and so on then apply an
ml model to extract embeddings from the
item features in this demo we used text
edings generated from the item
names lastly you create a new online
store instance that Imports the item
embeddings from the bigquery table by
specifying the sync setting the update
to the table will be automatically
copied to the online online store
periodically then you are ready to fetch
features from the online store when the
Shopper scans the item with the kiosk
you can use the item ID to retri the
item m benix in a few
milliseconds the ambix will be used to
find similar items shown to The
Shopper from the feature retrieval
similarity search and to show the result
to the
user it will it would only take a TENS
of milliseconds this is the real time AI
user experience you can build with the
new feature
store so you may be wondering can you
use any arbitrary big query table or
view as an online store the answer is
yes as long as the table or view follows
the conditions here the table should
have an ID should have an ID column and
the other columns should have the
supported data types it is recommended
to limit the low size up to 10 megab to
optimize the performance and also the
table should have should be stored in
the same region or M
region those are the conss now you can
deploy the feature vales to the online
store in three steps create online store
instance registered bigquery table or
View and set up a sync between
them so let's get into the
demo okay but I have prepared The
Notebook but it's too busy and too small
so that I actually copy and take a
screenshot of the important part so
let's look at those the screenshots of
the notebook so this is this is the
sport real shops bigquery table that has
the item id name category price and so
on then I use the ml. embed text
function of bigquery ml to extract the
text eming from the item name and save
them as a new table we will let feature
store with this table as feature values
to start working with feature store you
need to load the feature store SDK with
those inputs and get the
client with the client you can call the
function to create an online store
instance for the first time it can take
up to 10 minutes but after that you can
get the instance in a
second now with the online store
instance you need to register a big
query table as a feature view feature
view is a collection of features you
want to use on the online
service the last step is to set up the
sync between bigquery table and online
store here you specify the feature view
to start syncing and check the sync
process the syn time you will depend on
the amount of the data you are you are
thinking in this example my table has
about 30,000 rolls and the think took
about 3
minutes now the online store online
store is ready for serving let's take a
look at how you can use it in this
service in your online service you can
get the client for the online store and
call fetch feature values function by
passing the ID and that's it you you
will receive the feature values in a few
milliseconds you can use them for
further search and
recommendation the new feature store has
a low laty service as Alex mentions
which is ringly fast to test the
latencies I did a simple performance
test i l the full RP and measur the time
to F the values for 1,000 times the
result you are seeing is 2 milliseconds
so online store works just like a local
variable in your python code that holds
all the feature values automatically
copied from your big query table no need
for issuing SQL query and wait for
seconds to retrieve each item from
databases
there's one more things as as Alex
mentioned earlier the feature store can
support the retrieve uh can also support
retrieve items with similar emings
without the need to set up additional
Services here I passed the item ID to
find other items that have similar
embeddings notice that how I didn't have
to import any other Library set up
another service or copy data it's all
done by the feat store itself it returns
a list of the similar items and scores
that I can use for the ranking that's
really nice if I wanted to combine the
retried features for the recommendations
or sear use
cases lastly I'd like to share one more
cases of the shop scenario that is an LM
integration suppose you are adding an AI
chat Bard to the AI kiosk using the LM
like verx AI Palm
API also the shop has the big quity
table to track each C customer shopping
activities such as the Google analytics
log on the website or on-site item
search history so the feature store can
feed those activities in real
time now when the customer starts to
start the chatting with the AI Kos you
can argument LM prompt with the last
item the customer checked and have the
personalized chat
experience you can easily fetch the last
item from the online store for each
customer customer and build a prompt
like this in this case the customer had
interest in the crowd ve women's
Excursion shot so we want to we want the
LM to lead the conversations for closing
the deal with the item The Prompt goes
right this you are a personal shopping
assistant in the sportware shop this
customer looked at the croud women's
Excursion show last time start the
conversation to Closs the deal with this
with this
item an example of the conversation with
this prompt will be like this let's
listen to
it hello hello welcome to our store can
I help you find anything in particular
nothing particular what do you have we
have a wide variety of sportsware
including the cloudveil women's
Excursion short these shorts are great
for hiking camping or any other outdoor
activity they're made with a lightweight
water resistant fabric that will keep
you cool and dry even on the hottest
days would you like to take a closer
look so please note that I haven't
created any part of this chatbot answer
all generated by the pal API with the
prompt build with the feature store this
is an simple example but there is an
endless possibilities of what you can do
here hello oh sorry hello welcome to our
store can I help you find anything in
particular nothing particular what do
you
have so in summary the feature store
it's so easy to retrieve any features or
embeding value of the items or customers
or any other business entities in the
real time this enhances the ability of
of your machine running model for
realtime prediction similarity search or
recommendation also it empowers geni and
its us experim experience with the
dynamically built prompts so that was
the demo back to
[Applause]
Alex
so I've talked to you about the
challenges and making data in production
for machine learning I've described the
feature store made a few announcements
Cass showed you the demo we played the
audio segment twice what else can I do
to convince you that feature stores are
there and that you should be using them
well one of the coolest things about
working in vertex AI is that I get to
work with some of the
most advanced companies in Ai and I get
to advise them and also learn from them
on how to build
products and a few of those
companies sometimes go on record and
describe the experiences they had with
us building those
products one of those companies is
Wayfair they're one of the largest
retailers they're one of the largest
e-commerce stores for furniture in the
world and they say that that vertx a
feature store presents a major
operational win for their team they love
the big query
operations and they believe that feature
store has simplified their mlops
story another company that you probably
know is
Shopify the second largest retailer in
North
America and is really well known in
machine learning and data engineering
space and they said that the new vertex
a feature store is a significant
Improvement in the design of the featur
store they loved our low latency serving
it helps them create the magical
experiences that the company is well
known for and we work very closely with
that team to learn about how to build
feature stores what it means to have a
feature store in a large company there's
a lot of fun conversations we had about
the contracts between the future
producers and future
consumers but what's best about both of
those quotes is that both of these
companies are very well known in ml
space they have thousands of Engineers
definitely hundreds maybe not thousands
of ml engineers and both of them
chose to not build a feature store but
buy a feature store because this is the
type of product that may be best built
by a company like
Google so that about concludes my talk I
have one last thing to say the future
store is going to be a available in
September for everybody in this room and
everybody outside of this room we're
going to enter public preview by the end
of next month so you can start reaching
out to your sales
reps and getting on the
list I want to conclude by saying that
feature store is the type of product
that really for a lot of teams marks the
before and after era in their ml
maturity when implemented right and
adopted fully it really elevates your
entire ml
organization so I hope to see you as one
of the future store customers and I
can't wait to hear what you get to build
with it thank
you